This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Abby Mars grew up in Brooklyn and married a guy she'd known since they were kids. Their first son, David, was born in 1968. By the time David was two, Abby noticed something was different about him. David's face would twitch. He sometimes made involuntary noises. His arms flailed around out of control, so he could barely feed himself. He was very disturbed by the movements because other kids would make fun of him. David's teachers often got upset with him in class.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。艾比·迈尔斯在布鲁克林长大，嫁给了一个她从小就认识的人。他们的第一个儿子大卫于1968年出生。在大卫两岁时，艾比注意到他有些不对劲。大卫的脸会抽搐。他有时会发出不由自主的声音。他的手臂失控地挥舞着，几乎无法自己喂饭。这些动作让他感到非常困扰，因为其他孩子会嘲笑他。大卫的老师在课堂上也经常对感到他很不满。
So you can imagine the torture that he went through. One Sunday morning, when David was eight, Abby watched him try to read the funnies, but he couldn't keep his head steady enough. It was heartbreaking. That's producer Dan Weissman, the host of a new podcast about the cost of healthcare called an arm and a leg. Watching David struggle with the comics,
所以你可以想象他经历的折磨。一个周日的早晨，大卫八岁时，艾比看着他试图阅读搞笑漫画，但他无法让自己的头部保持足够的稳定。这太令人心碎了。那是制作人丹·韦斯曼，一档名为《一条胳膊和一条腿》的新播客的主持人，该播客探讨了医疗保健的成本。看着大卫与漫画作斗争，
Abby was ready to cry. She put off doing the dishes, sat down, and picked up another section of the paper. And through total coincidence, there was an article about a teenager who had symptoms just like David's, facial tics, weird noisems, flailing limbs. Abby and her husband brought the article to David's pediatrician, and the doctor agreed this story described exactly what David had. This condition will sound familiar to you, but at the time most people, even doctors, had never heard of it. It was called Tourette Syndrome.
艾比快要哭了。她放下手中的碗盘，坐下来，拿起了报纸的另一个版块。通过完全的巧合，上面有一篇关于一个青少年的文章，他的症状和大卫一模一样：面部抽搐、奇怪的噪声、四肢挥舞。艾比和她的丈夫把这篇文章拿给大卫的儿科医生看，医生一致认为这个故事准确地描述了大卫的情况。这种病你会觉得耳熟，但在当时大多数人，甚至医生，从未听说过它。它被称为妥瑞症。
Speaking to doctors, many doctors, after that, they said they never heard of it because they simply were not taught very much about rare diseases in medical school. And back then, when so few people had heard of it, Tourette's was considered super rare. It just seemed bizarre to me that I got a diagnosis out of a Sunday newspaper. From there, Abby found a specialist who eventually turned her on to a potential treatment for Tourette's syndrome that was being tested out in clinical trials. Well, it wasn't being tested for Tourette's. The drug company was mainly hoping to market this drug for schizophrenia. The particularly drug had been made available in Europe for a while and doctors knew it worked on turrets. So David got in on a trial for this drug with the hopes that it could be approved in the US and it turned out it worked really well for him.
在那之后，在与许多医生交谈时，他们说从未听说过它，因为他们在医学院里根本没有学到太多关于罕见病的知识。在那个时候，当听到过它的人少之又少时，妥瑞症被认为是超级罕见的。我从星期日报纸上得到一个诊断，这对我来说简直太奇怪了。从那时起，艾比找到了一位专家，他最终向她介绍了妥瑞症的潜在治疗方法，该方法正在临床试验中进行测试。好吧，它不是针对妥瑞症进行测试的。这家制药公司主要希望将这种药推向精神分裂症市场。这种特定的药物已经在欧洲使用了一段时间，医生们知道它对妥瑞症有效。因此，大卫参加了这种药物的试验，希望它能在美国获得批准，事实证明它对他非常有效。
But the drug trials didn't go as well for schizophrenia, which was supposed to be its more common use. So the drug company decided the market wasn't big enough. They just dropped the drug entirely. And so companies just said no, they wouldn't do it. They wouldn't make the drug, they wouldn't sell it. And this is how Abby learned a term that would define the next few decades of her life. Orphan drugs. Orphan drugs. As Abby learned, drug companies weren't interested in developing treatments for rare conditions, because the big money was in drugs with tons of customers, and biotics are drugs for stuff like diabetes, high cholesterol.
但药物试验对于本应是其更常见用途的精神分裂症来说并不顺利。因此，制药公司认为市场不够大。他们直接放弃了这种药物。因此，公司只是说不，他们不会这样做的。他们不会制造这种药，也不会出售它。这就是艾比学到一个将定义她未来几十年人生的词汇的方式：孤儿药。孤儿药。正如艾比所了解到的，制药公司对开发针对罕见病的疗法不感兴趣，因为大笔资金都在拥有大量客户的药物中，比如糖尿病、高胆固醇等药物。
They just didn't think selling a drug for terats would be a big money maker. So promising treatments like the one that had been working for David became orphan drugs, with no pharma company to raise them. To keep herself from going nuts with frustration, Abby Myers joined the Tourette Syndrome Association. It was pretty small. They immediately invited her to join the board and asked her what she wanted to be in
他们只是不认为出售治疗妥瑞症的药物能赚大钱。因此，像对大卫管用的那种有前途的疗法变成了孤儿药，没有制药公司愿意抚养它们。为了不让自己沮丧到发疯，艾比·迈尔斯加入了妥瑞症协会。它相当小。他们立刻邀请她加入董事会，并问她想负责什么。
charge of. I sure that that wanted to become the fundraiser or the arranger of special dinners or anything like that. And I wasn't a doctor, so I didn't want to do the research end of it. That left lobbying and advocacy, spreading awareness. Abby started figuring out how to do that. And she found a mentor. Her name was Marjorie Guthrie. Marjorie was the widow of Woody Guthrie, the iconic American folk singer who wrote the song, This Land Is Your Land.
我确信那想成为筹款人、特别晚宴的安排者或类似的事情。我不是医生，所以不想从事研究端的工作。那就剩下游说、倡导和传播意识了。艾比开始摸索如何做到这一点。她找到了一个导师。她的名字叫玛乔莉·格思里。玛乔莉是伍迪·格思里的遗孀，伍迪是美国标志性的民谣歌手，曾写过《这片土地是你的土地》这首歌。
Woody had died in the 1960s of Huntington's another rare disease. She was on a mission for her whole life, which was to find the answers for Huntington's disease. Marjorie was great at it. By the time Abby Myers started lobbying, everybody connected with rare diseases, new Marjorie Guthrie. Abby took note of one of Marjorie's best tricks.
伍迪在20世纪60年代死于另一种罕见病亨廷顿舞蹈症。她毕生的使命就是为亨廷顿舞蹈症寻找答案。玛乔莉在这方面很在行。当艾比·迈尔斯开始游说时，所有与罕见病相关的人都认识玛乔莉·格思里。艾比注意到了玛乔莉的绝招之一。
Marjorie would be talking with scientists or farm executives, and they'd be using technical jargon. She's saying, please talk to me in plain English. I'm just a housewife. And they would. And when experts couldn't hide behind technical jargon, Marjorie Guthrie would pin them down, put them on the record, and use their words as ammunition.
玛乔莉会和科学家或制药高管交谈，他们会使用技术术语。她说，请用白话跟我说话。我只是个家庭主妇。他们照办了。当专家无法躲在技术术语背后时，玛乔莉·格思里就会逼问他们，把他们的话记录在案，并把他们的话作为弹药。
For instance, she could get experts to explain exactly how promising a proposed drug might be, and why they wouldn't sell it. And all of that would be in there, in plain English. So when Abby started meeting with government officials, she introduced herself the same way, just a housewife. She figured it wouldn't be a bad thing to let them underestimate her a little.
例如，她可以让专家准确解释一种拟议的药物有多大前景，以及他们为什么不卖它。所有这些都会用通俗易懂的英语记录在里面。因此，当艾比开始会见政府官员时，她也是这样介绍自己的：只是个家庭主妇。她觉得让他们稍微低估自己并不是一件坏事。
I found that people wanted to think about a woman as somebody who's just trying to raise her kids. She's just a housewife. By June 1980, Abby and Marjorie and their allies got a California congressman to hold a hearing to call attention to the problem of orphan drugs. This was their big chance to finally have a national audience to put pharma companies on the spot to make them face the patients who were waiting for treatments. Maybe this hearing could really change things.
我发现人们愿意把一个女人想象成一个只想把孩子养大的人。她只是个家庭主妇。到1980年6月，艾比、玛乔莉和她们的盟友找到了一位加州国会议员，要求举行听证会，以引起人们对孤儿药问题的关注。这是她们的绝佳机会，终于可以拥有全国性的观众，将制药公司推上风口浪尖，让他们直面等待治疗的患者。也许这次听证会真的能改变现状。
Well, nobody from the pharmaceutical industry showed up. Also, hardly any elected representatives showed up. Well, no Republicans at all showed up. Maybe one or two congressmen stuck their head in and sat down for five minutes and then left. The gallery was pretty empty too. It was like nobody was there except the very, very last row in the room.
好吧，没有一个制药行业的人出席。而且，几乎没有任何民选代表出席。好吧，没有一个共和党人出席。也许有一两个国会议员露了个脸，坐了五分钟然后就走了。旁听席也很空。就像没有人在那里一样，除了房间里最最最后一排。
A young man was sitting there and I had no idea who he was. And it turned out that he was a reporter for the Los Angeles Times. That reporter was there because for him, it was a local story. One of the people testifying a teenage boy with Tourette's was from Los Angeles. It resulted in a very short story buried in the middle of the paper where nobody was likely to see it.
一个年轻人在那里坐着，我完全不知道他是谁。结果发现他是《洛杉矶时报》的一名记者。那个记者在那里是因为对多他来说，这是一个地方新闻。其中一个作证的人是一个患有妥瑞症的十几岁男孩，来自洛杉矶。这导致了一篇非常短的文章被埋在报纸中间，没有人会看到它。
Fix up somebody dead. If you're old enough to have watched TV in the 1970s, the name Jack Klugeman will instantly conjure a raspy voice, slightly pudgy New Yorker. The sitcom The Odd Couple was huge. Jack Klugeman played a middle-aged slob whose roommates with a neat freak. What's this, Joe? Christmas present. I forgot to give it to you.
整顿一个死人。如果你年龄大到在20世纪70年代看电视，杰克·克卢格曼这个名字会立刻让人联想到沙哑的声音、稍微有点胖的纽约人。情景喜剧《单身公寓》非常火爆。杰克·克卢格曼饰演一个中年懒汉，他的室友是个有洁癖的人。这是什么，乔？圣诞礼物。我忘给你了。
Merry Christmas. But is it? Assorted Jesus. When that show ended, Jack Klugman got his own brand new TV show, a kind of detective series. He played a medical examiner called Quincy. The Quincy Show, which was nice and entertainment about a doctor who looked at dead bodies and decided who the murderer was.
圣诞快乐。但真的是吗？各种耶稣。当那个节目结束时，杰克·克卢格曼有了他自己的全新电视节目，一种侦探系列。他扮演一个名叫昆西的法医。昆西秀，这是一个很好的娱乐节目，讲述一个医生检查尸体并决定谁是凶手的故事。
It was like a precursor to CSI, and it was kind of a big deal at the time. Gentlemen, you are about to enter the most fascinating sphere of police work, the world of forensic medicine. And after that little story, the Los Angeles Times came out. Abby got a call from some of the few said he was a producer on the Quincy Show. She was skeptical. I said yes, and I'm Mrs. Santa Claus. But after a few minutes on the phone, she realized the guy was telling the truth.
这有点像《犯罪现场调查》的前身，在当时是一件大事。绅士们，你们即将进入警察工作中最迷人的领域，法医医学的世界。在那个小故事之后，《洛杉矶时报》出版了。艾比接到了一些人的电话，其中一个人说他是《昆西秀》的制作人。她持怀疑态度。我说对，我是圣诞老人太太。但在电话里聊了几分钟后，她意识到这家伙说的是真的。
He was a producer for Quincy, and he happened to have a fairly rare disease himself. In fact, he was dying of bone cancer. And so he said this whole thing with orphan drugs is a beautiful story and I'd really like to do an episode of Quincy about it. And this producer had the pull to make it happen. His name was Maurice Klugeman. He was Jack Klugeman's brother. I mean these things happen in the movies. They don't happen to real people, but that's what happens. The episode actually got made. It happened. And in the episode, a teenager with Tourette dies under suspicious circumstances. Turns out it's not exactly a murder, but by the time Quincy figures that out, he meets another
他是昆西的制作人，而且他自己碰巧患有一种相当罕见的疾病。事实上，他正死于骨癌。所以他说，整个孤儿药的故事太棒了，我真的很想做一集关于它的《昆西》。这个制作人有影响力让它成为现实。他的名字叫莫里斯·克卢格曼。他是杰克·克卢格曼的兄弟。我的意思是这些事情只发生在电影里。它们不会发生在真人身上，但这就是发生的事情。那一集真的拍出来了。它发生了。在那一集中，一个患有妥瑞症的青少年在可疑情况下死亡。原来这并非谋杀，但当昆西弄清楚这一点时，他遇到了另一个
young man with Tourette's and gets obsessed with the problem of orphan drugs. Here's Quincy, talking with that kid's dad. So if you've got a disease that happens to have a low incidence, don't count on the pharmaceutical companies for any help. That's why they call them orphan drugs. Miracles, the cures for rare diseases that no one wants to adopt. Well, isn't there a bill before Congress
患有妥瑞症的年轻人，并对孤儿药的问题着迷了。这是昆西和那个孩子的爸爸的对话。所以如果你得了一种发病率很低的疾病，不要指望制药公司提供任何帮助。这就是为什么他们称之为孤儿药。奇迹，没有人愿意收养的罕见病的疗法。那么，国会里不是有一项法案吗？
that's supposed to deal with all this? The orphan drug bill, it's still being considered. The show suddenly goes from on mystery to a policy drama. Quincy goes all in on the orphan drugs issue. He lobbies, farmer companies, the FDA, congressman becomes a total policy nerd. At the big finish, the kid with Tourette's, after a pep talk by Quincy, gives a blockbuster speech at a congressional hearing.
应该处理所有这些吗？孤儿药法案仍在审议中。节目突然从一个谜团变成了政策剧。昆西全力投入到孤儿药问题中。他游说制药公司、FDA、国会议员，成了一个彻头彻尾的政策迷。在最后的大结局中，患有妥瑞症的孩子在昆西的鼓舞下，在国会听证会上发表了一场重磅演讲。
I'm thinking about the other victims. Not just of Tourette's, but anyone who is unlucky enough to have a disease that never made it to the top 40. This congressional hearing was obviously fictional, but it got a real world response. When that show was broadcast, Jack Klugman received thousands and thousands of letters. And they didn't even open up. They just had these big sacks, they were like, Santa Claus sacks, and they stuffed all the mail into them, and they sent all of those sacks to me.
我在想其他受害者。不仅仅是妥瑞症，还有任何不幸患上从未进入前40名的疾病的人。这场国会听证会显然是虚构的，但它得到了现实世界的反响。当那个节目播出时，杰克·克卢格曼收到了成千上万的信件。他们甚至没有拆开。他们只是有这些大麻袋，就像圣诞老人的麻袋一样，他们把所有的信件塞进麻袋里，把所有这些麻袋都寄给了我。
The letters were from people with rare diseases, and people who just wanted to do something to help solve the orphan drug problem. With this kind of publicity and support, Abby and her friends got another congressional hearing. On March 10, 1981, real-life elected officials heard testimony about a real-life proposal to create financial incentives for pharma companies to take on orphan drugs. On hand to give that proposal a boost of star power was Jack Klegman himself. The actor flew to Washington and testified in this new hearing in Congress.
这些信来自患有罕见病的人，以及那些只想做点什么来帮助解决孤儿药问题的人。凭借这种宣传和支持，艾比和她的朋友们举行了另一场国会听证会。1981年3月10日，现实生活中的民选官员听取了关于一项现实生活提案的证词，该提案旨在为制药公司承担孤儿药创造经济激励。杰克·克卢格曼本人亲自到场为该提案注入了明星般的动力。这位演员飞往华盛顿，并在国会的新听证会上作证。
This time it was packed. People just sat down on the floor in the aisles. It was pednimonium because Jack Klegman was in the room. I'm telling you, Jack Klegman was a big deal in those days. An orphan drug bill passed the house, but it got stalled in the Senate, where Abby heard a single senator was secretly blocking it. It was rumored to be orange hatch. So Jack Clogman and his crew swing into action.
这次是座无虚席。人们直接坐在过道的地板上。这里一片混乱，因为杰克·克卢格曼在房间里。我告诉你，杰克·克卢格曼在那些日子里可是个大人物。孤儿药法案在众议院获得通过，但在参议院陷入僵局，艾比听说有一个参议员在暗中阻止它。传闻是奥林·哈奇。所以杰克·克卢格曼和他的团队开始行动了。
They do another episode of Quincy, one where a single senator is holding up an orphan drug bill. In the climactic scene, Quincy confronts that senator in his DC office. If I choose to keep voting against this bill it's something because I think it's in the best interest of the election. Then you should be ready for the reaction. There won't be any reaction. I play this course too many times.
他们制作了另一集《昆西》，讲述一个参议员阻挠孤儿药法案的故事。在全剧高潮的场景中，昆西在他在华盛顿特区的办公室里与那位参议员对峙。如果我选择继续投票反对这项法案，那是因为我认为这符合选举的最佳利益。那么你应该准备好迎接反应。不会有任何反应。这个过程我经历过太多次了。
Well, maybe the rules have been changed. Why don't you take a look at the window, Senator? The Senator glances incredulously toward the window. Then, back to Quincy. Then, both guys turn and walk solemnly over this huge picture window. And out in the street, there's a big demonstration heading straight toward the
好吧，也许规则已经改变了。参议员，你为什么不看一眼窗外？参议员难以置信地瞥了一眼窗户。然后，又看向昆西。然后，两个人转身，神情凝重地走向这扇巨大的落地窗。在街上，有一场大规模的游行正径直朝向
senator's office. The camera gently zooms past the two men and focuses on the action outside. There are hundreds of people, lots of them in wheelchairs, and they've got colorful signs with slogans like, now is the time, vote for the orphan drug bill and in a direct pitch to the fictional senator watching through the window, we need you, Senator Reeves. This sequence lingers and lingers and lingers. These extras were all actual people with rare diseases that Abbey Myers and her colleagues recruited, except not actually in Washington. They shot it in Pasadena where the weather was better. The fake march on Washington totally worked. The fake senator on the show chaved.
参议员的办公室走去。镜头缓缓越过这两个男人，聚焦在室外的行动上。有几百人，许多人坐在轮椅上，他们拿着色彩鲜艳的牌子，上面写着诸如“现在是时候了，投票支持孤儿药法案”等口号，直接向通过窗户观看的虚构参议员喊话：“我们需要你，里夫斯参议员。”这个镜头持续了又持续，持续了又持续。这些群演都是艾比·迈尔斯和她的同事招募的真正患有罕见病的人，只不过他们实际上不在华盛顿。他们在天气更好的帕萨迪纳拍摄的。虚假的华盛顿游行完全成功了。剧中的假参议员改变了主意。
I cannot support this bill, but I want that in its way. And so did the real life senator. Or an hatch. There would not be an orphan drug act if it was not for that episode of Quincy. The orphan drug act passed the Senate. President Ronald Reagan signed it into law and the fake march on Washington became, in some people's minds, a real life event. People would say to me that March on March, it was wonderful. There wasn't a March on March, it was.
我不能支持这项法案，但我希望它以它自己的方式通过。现实生活中的参议员也是如此。奥林·哈奇。如果没有《昆西》那一集，就不会有《孤儿药法案》。《孤儿药法案》在参议院获得通过。罗纳德·里根总统将其签署为法律，在某些人看来，虚假的华盛顿游行变成了一场现实生活中的活动。人们会对我说，那场三月的游行太棒了。根本没有什么三月游行，那是演的。
But you know, it was on TV, so. Abby Myers went on to help start a new advocacy group, the National Organization for Rare Disorders, and she ran it for more than 20 years. But these days, when people ask her about her legacy, this is what she tells them. Be careful what you wish for. It might come true. The Orphan Drug Act of 1983 created financial incentives
但你知道，它在电视上播出了，所以。艾比·迈尔斯后来帮助创立了一个新的倡导组织——全国罕见疾病组织，她管理了它20多年。但如今，当人们问及她的传奇经历时，她总是这样告诉他们：小心你许下的愿望。它可能会成真。1983年的《孤儿药法案》创造了经济激励，
for pharma companies to develop drugs to treat orphan conditions. The Orphan Drug Act basically says once the FDA agrees proposed treatment will address a rare condition under current definitions that means it affects fewer than 200,000 people in the US, then the developer qualifies for special goodies. That includes subsidies like actual tax payer cash for clinical trials and a big prize at the end. The first drug company to get FDA approval for a certain kind of treatment gets market exclusivity. Basically, I'm an OPLI. No one else can market an equivalent drug in the US for seven years. Which means that during that seven-year period, the company gets a chance to make money off
鼓励制药公司开发治疗孤儿病的药物。《孤儿药法案》基本上规定，一旦FDA同意拟议的疗法将解决罕见病（根据目前的定义，这意味着它影响美国不到20万人的群体），那么开发商就有资格获得特殊的福利。这包括补贴，例如用于临床试验的实际纳税人现金，以及最终的大奖。第一家获得FDA批准某种疗法的制药公司将获得市场独占权。基本上，我是唯一的。在七年内，没有人能在美国销售同类药物。这意味着在这七年期间，公司有机会通过设定高于平常的价格，
this drug even if relatively few people use, by setting a higher than usual price. You know, if you have a drug for high blood pressure, it's probably half of the United States needs blood pressure medicine, but with a rare disease. You're not going to make money if you charge a normal price for those. And then drug companies realized that if they had a monopoly, they didn't have to charge anything that would be remotely considered a normal price. They could charge pretty much whatever they wanted, especially if the insurance companies were paying for it. It took pharma companies a few years to catch on to how good a deal the orphan drug act
即使使用人数相对较少，也能从中赚钱。你知道，如果你有一种治疗高血压的药物，可能有一半的美国人需要降压药，但对于罕见病。如果你对这些药物收取正常价格，你是赚不到钱的。然后制药公司意识到，如果他们拥有垄断地位，他们就不必收取任何可以勉强算是正常价格的费用。他们几乎可以收取他们想要的任何费用，特别是如果保险公司为此买单的话。制药公司花了几年时间才明白《孤儿药法案》能带来多大的好处，但到了20世纪90年代，事情绝对在顺利进行。
could be, but by the 1990s, things were definitely rolling. One rare disease drug came out in 1991 with a price tag of $150,000 a year. It was huge money. I've been involved in the formation and financing of biotechnology and healthcare companies for almost 30 years. This is Josh Washine, and he's one of the many entrepreneurs who took advantage of the orphan drug policy. His path to the big farm of money led through Las Vegas. It illustrates just how wild west this new world could be.
一种罕见病药物于1991年问世，标价为每年15万美元。这是一笔巨款。我参与生物技术和医疗保健公司的成立和融资已经近30年了。这是乔希·沃什恩，他是利用孤儿药政策的众多企业家之一。他通往大制药公司金钱的道路经过了拉斯维加斯。这说明了这个新世界会有多疯狂。
In 2003 Joshua Shine started a company called Lev Pharmaceuticals and this company had just one mission, a single thing it was going to do. Lev Pharmaceuticals was going to market a drug for a rare disorder called hereditary angiodeima. Actually, the drug already existed. It had been used successfully in Europe for 30 years, but nobody had taken it through clinical trials in the US. As shine recalls, that looked like a good setup. It seemed like a very good opportunity from its inception.
2003年，约书亚·沙因创办了一家名为莱夫制药（Lev Pharmaceuticals）的公司，这家公司只有一个使命，一件要做的事情。莱夫制药将销售一种治疗遗传性血管性水肿的罕见病的药物。其实，这种药早就存在了。它在欧洲已经成功使用了30年，但没有人带它在美国进行临床试验。正如沙因回忆的那样，这看起来是一个不错的开端。从一开始，这似乎就是一个非常好的机会。
We saw a serious unmet clinical need in the US. To bring this treatment from Europe to the point where it could be sold in the US, meant that Joshua Shine would have to raise enough money for lab pharmaceuticals to run clinical trials for FDA approval, which would be a lot easier to do as a publicly traded company. And that's how they found Fun City Popcorn. created company. And that's how they found Fun City Popcorn. Right, it's not a typical path
我们在美国看到了严重未得到满足的临床需求。要将这种疗法从欧洲引进并在美国销售，意味着约书亚·沙因必须为莱夫制药筹集足够的资金来进行FDA批准的临床试验，作为一家上市公司，这要容易得多爆米花。一家创立的公司。这就是他们找到趣味城市爆米花的方式。没错，这不是一条典型的道路，
and that's really not a typical name for it. A biotech company. Fun City Popcorn sold popcorn and nacho cheese sauce to concessionaires all around Las Vegas. They had hundreds of clients, malls, ball parks, skating rinks, unit. But of course, Lev didn't pursue fun city for their nacho cheese sauce recipe.
而且对于一家生物技术公司来说，这确实不是一个典型的名字。趣味城市爆米花向拉斯维加斯各地的特许经营商出售爆米花和纳乔奶酪酱。他们有数百个客户，包括商场、棒球场、溜冰场等。但是，当然，莱夫并不是为了他们的纳乔奶酪酱配方而追求趣味城市的。
It turned out Fun City's owners were getting out of the popcorn and concession business, and they were game to try something new. Fun City agreed to actually merge with Lev Pharmaceuticals. Thus, bestowing on Lev, their status as a publicly traded company, which made it easier for Lev to attract even more investors. But for a few months until they could get the paperwork sorted out, they had to go by the name, Fun City Popcorn.
事实证明，趣味城市的业主正在退出爆米花和特许经营业务，他们愿意尝试新事物。趣味城市同意与莱夫制药公司实际合并。因此，赋予了莱夫上市公司地位，这使得莱夫更容易吸引更多的投资者。但在几个月的时间里，直到他们把纸质文件整理好，他们不得不使用“趣味城市爆米花”这个名字。
We felt we could overcome the man in Fun City Popcorn and had the jokes that might bring up. Did people kid you about it? Sure. Still do it, darling. Shine could laugh all the way to the bank. Over the next few years, Lev Pharmaceuticals raised about $75 million
我们觉得我们可以克服趣味城市爆米花带来的影响，以及可能随之而来的笑话。人们会拿它开玩笑吗？当然。现在还在开玩笑，亲爱的。沙因可以一路笑着去银行。在接下来的几年里，莱夫制药筹集了大约7500万美元，
to pay for the clinical trials that would win FDA approval. Of course, Joshua Shine still had to get the trials done and do it before anyone else. After all, the orphan drug act is set up to give a monopoly to whoever gets to the treatment first. Finishing second, can mean losing the whole investment. It was a real horse race to see you could finish the trials first.
用于支付赢得FDA批准的临床试验费用。当然，约书亚·沙因仍然必须完成试验，而且必须在其他人之前完成。毕竟，《孤儿药法案》旨在将垄断权赋予率先获得治疗方案的人。拿到第二名，可能意味着血本无归。这是一场真正的赛马，看谁能先完成试验。
And Shine won this particular race. Yeah, I'm very pleased with how this worked out. It worked out most importantly for patients. And of course, he's also glad it worked out for the shareholders. Most companies don't pan out. And so, you know, I'm pleased that as managers of a company that we were able to provide a return for our shareholders. It was a big return. In 2008, a couple weeks before the FDA gave the new drug its final approval, Lev Pharmaceuticals sold for $442 million.
沙因赢得了这场特殊的比赛。是的，我对这个结果非常满意。最重要的是，这对患者来说结果很好。当然，他也高兴这对股东来说也算圆满。大多数公司都以失败告终。所以，你知道，我很高兴作为公司的管理者，我们能够为我们的股东提供回报。这是一个巨大的回报。2008年，在FDA对新药给予最终批准前几周，莱夫制药以4.42亿美元的价格售出。
for $442 million. And within a few years, the new owner was making $400 million back from this one drug every year, thanks to a price tag that made this one of the world's most expensive drugs, more than half a million bucks a year per patient. And then, that owner sold itself to a still bigger company for $4.2 billion. That company CEO says that the company's entire strategy is to make money from the treatment of rare diseases. The Orphan Drug Act and the crazy pricing that is its legacy is this company's whole vision for making tons of money.
以4.42.亿美元的价格。几年之内，新主人每年仅从这种药上就能收回4亿美元，多亏了一个标价，让它成为世界上最昂贵的药物之一，每位患者每年花费超过五十万美元。然后，该主人以42亿美元的价格将自己出售给了一家更大的公司。该公司首席执行官表示，该公司的整个战略就是从罕见病的治疗中赚钱。《孤儿药法案》及其遗留下的疯狂定价是这家公司赚取巨额资金的整个愿景。
This is why Abbey Myers has mixed feelings about her legacy. Thirty-five years later, the orphan drug act has been responsible for the most miraculous treatments and many, many diseases. But some of the companies that make these drugs have put prices on them that make the drugs absolutely unaffordable. In other words, it's like a ransom note for thousands of desperately ill people. Joshua Shine from Lebpharmaceuticals has a different perspective. He says it is hard enough to get money to develop these drugs, even with the orphan drug acts incentive, but massive payout. These drugs are hugely expensive to develop, and the failures far, far outnumber the successes,
这就是为什么艾比·迈尔斯对她的传奇经历有着复杂的感情。三十五年后，《孤儿药法案》为许多疾病带来了最奇迹般的治疗方法。但生产这些药物的一些公司为其定下了令人咋换的价格，使得这些药物完全让人负担不起。换句话说，这就像是给成千上万绝症患者的一封勒索信。来自莱夫制药的约书亚·沙因有不同的看法。他说，即便有《孤儿药法案》的激励和巨额回报，要筹集资金来开发这些药物也已经足够困难了。这些药物的开发成本极高，失败的次数远远多于成功，
and without a system in place like the orphan drug act, the drugs would not come to market. Of course, it doesn't have to be this way. I'd be Myers and others have their own proposals for how to balance incentives with reasonable prices. It's a giant debate. If you look at a list of the most expensive drugs, you'll notice two things. They are unbelievably expensive, tens of thousands of dollars a month,
如果没有像《孤儿药法案》这样现成的系统，这些药物根本无法问世。当然，事情不一定非得如此。艾比·迈尔斯和其他人有他们自己的提议，探讨如何在激励措施和合理价格之间取得平衡。这是一场巨大的辩论。如果你看一下最昂贵药物的清单，你会发现两件事。它们贵得不可思议，一个月就要几万美元，
and they are generally for rare conditions. Whoever pays an individual bill insurance companies patients The whole thing contributes to the spiraling cost of health care And it's gonna take more than I've faked TV march on Washington to fix the problem If you'd like to know more about how the cost of healthcare has gotten so messed up and what we may be able to do about it, or if you just like really good storytelling, check out Dan Weissman's new podcast. It's called The Arm in a Leg.
而且它们通常用于罕见疾病。无论是谁支付个人的账单：保险公司还是患者，这一切都在导致医疗保健成本螺旋式上升。要解决这个问题，需要的可不仅仅是我们在华盛顿虚构的电视游行。如果你想了解更多关于医疗保健成本是如何变得如此一团糟的，以及我们可能做些什么来解决它，或者如果你只是喜欢非常棒的故事讲述，请查看丹·韦斯曼的新播客。它叫《一条胳膊和一条腿》。
We'll have more about that show after the break. Dan Weissman is a journalist based in Chicago. You may remember that he reported a couple stories with us over the years about the reversing of the Chicago River and how the popularity of Billi billions drove the development of plastics. And as we mentioned, he now has a show about healthcare called an arm and a leg. I asked him why he was compelled to create a podcast about this particular subject. I've kind of been interested in this topic for a long time and partly for personal reasons.
休息过后，我们将为您带来关于该节目的更多内容。丹·韦斯曼是一位常驻芝加哥的记者。你可能还记得，这些年来，他曾与我们合作报道过几个故事，比如芝加哥河的逆流，以及数十亿人的流行如何推动了塑料的发展。正如我们所提到的，他现在有一个关于医疗保健的节目，叫做《一条胳膊和一条腿》。我问他为什么非得制作一档关于这个特定主题的播客。我长期以来一直对这个话题很感兴趣，部分是出于个人原因。
I had thought about going out of my own as a reporter instead of having working for somebody else for a while, something I wanted to do, but who's going to buy the health insurance for our family? My wife has her own business, and so it just seemed unthinkable. I found myself kind of having left one job thinking like, crap, crap, I might need a new career, which was really, you know, sad for me, that I was like, well, there is this one thing that's kind of running my life, and I know I'm not the only person,
我曾考虑过作为一个记者单干，而不是为别人工作一段时间，这是我想做的事情，但是谁来为我们家的医疗保险买单呢？我妻子有她自己的生意，所以这似乎是不可想象的。我发现自己有点离开了一份工作，心想：糟糕，糟糕，我可能需要一份新职业，这对我来说真的很（你知道的）悲伤，因为我想，好吧，确实有这么一件事在操纵着我的生活，我知道我不是唯一的一个，
which is, you know, the cost of healthcare and the need for health insurance and the expense of that, you know, just drives so many decisions for so many people. I don't see a conversation about that or a kind of accessible conversation about, like how do we get here? And it's like, is there anything any of us can do about it?
也就是（你知道的）医疗保健的成本、对医疗保险的需求以及它的开销，（你知道的）它驱使了那么多人为那么多事情做出决定。我没有看到关于这方面的对话，也没有看到关于“我们是怎么走到这一步的”那种平易近人的对话。就像，我们当中有人能对此做点什么吗？
And is how did we get here the driving question or is it how do we solve it? Like where do you place the emphasis in the show? That is a super good question. It's a good question. I think because of my disposition, there are some good stories in how we got here. I think that there's two good things about that. One is that understanding how we got here might help us understand a little bit about how we could make things a little better. And also that like one of the things,
“我们是怎么走到这一步的”是核心问题，还是“我们该如何解决它”？你在节目中把重点放在哪里？这是一个极好的问题。这是一个好问题。我想由于我的性格，在我们如何走到这一步的过程中有一些好故事。我认为这有两点好处。一个是理解我们是怎么走到这一步的，可能会帮助我们理解一点我们如何能把事情做得更好一点。还有一点，就像其中的一件事，
in some way the thing that I most want the show to do is that it allows us to be company for each other, right? That like we're all kind of scared and angry and confused and telling some interesting maybe fun stories is also just a way to pass the time and bring our blood pressure down to the point we actually could like see our way clear to doing something else about it. As you've been gathering the stories, is there an underlying theme that's emerged that
在某种程度上，我最希望这个节目做到的是，它让我们能够彼此陪伴，对吧？就像我们都感到害怕、愤怒和困惑，讲一些有趣甚至可能好笑的故事，也只是打发时间的一种方式，把我们的血压降下来，直到我们真正能够清晰地看到自己有能力对此做点别的什么。在收集这些故事的过程中，有没有出现什么让你感到惊讶的潜在主题？
surprised you? The thing that surprised me first was just from talking to people about the idea of doing this show that like every single person I would talk to him. This is I'd say pretty much remained true. Well, either right off the bat or as we get to talking, be like, oh yeah, well, this is a story that happened to me. But that was probably the single biggest surprise was like everybody, everybody. So you have one of these examples in your pilot
首先让我感到惊讶的是，仅仅是与人们谈论制作这个节目的想法，就像我与之交谈的每一个人。可以说这基本上一直是真的。要么一开始，要么当我们开始交谈时，就会说：“哦，是的，嗯，这是一个发生在我身上的故事。”但这可能是最让人惊奇的事情，就像每个人，每一个人都是如此。所以你的试播集中就有这样一个例子，
with your friend Peter. Could you describe the situation with Peter? Yeah, Peter is a real estate developer and he makes a perfectly good salary. And when I tell him I'm doing this show, he's like, oh, yeah, you know, the health insurance at my job just keeps getting worse and worse and last year my deductible was like $13,000
关于你的朋友彼得。你能描述一下彼得的情况吗？是的，彼得是一个房地产开发商，他拿着相当不错的薪水。当我告诉他我在做这个节目时，他会说：“哦，是的，你知道，我工作中的医疗保险变得越来越糟糕，去年我的免赔额大约是13,000美元，
in this year, it's worse. And yeah, and he's like, oh, wait, and did I tell you about when I had the kidney stone last year? I like no, he's like well, you know I Put off going to get help for as long as I possibly could because he was like they're just gonna charge him money And not people to do anything for him and he finally breaks down and his wife makes him go to the hospital and they give him an MRI and He is kicking himself and they told me exactly what I knew that I had a kidney stone and It was passing and I'm like thank you very much and then I get the bill Well, it was $6500. Oh my god, and you had it was all on you
今年更糟糕。”而且，是的，他说：“哦，等等，我有没有跟你说过我去年得肾结石的时候？”我说没有。他说：“嗯，你知道，我尽可能长时间地拖延不去寻求帮助，因为他觉得他们只会收他的钱，而不会为他做任何事情。”他终于崩溃了，他的妻子逼他去医院，他们给他做了磁共振，他正在责备自己。他们告诉我我早就知道的事：我得了肾结石，它正在通过。我说谢谢你们，然后我收到了账单。好吧，那是6500美元。我的天哪，而且全得你一个人承担？
It was all on me. It didn't help me in any way shape or form and then I'm left with this bill Peter one of the things that I find helped me in any way shape or form. And then I'm left with this bill. Peter, one of the things that I find you know, awful and delicious about this story is like it's not just your real estate developer, you know, you make a good salary, your real estate developer like negotiating with people like say contractors who most people would never think
全得我一个人承担。它对我没有任何形式的帮助。然后我留下了这张账单。彼得，我发现这件事最（你知道的）糟糕又绝妙的地方在于，你不仅仅是一个房地产开发商，（你知道的）你拿着不错的薪水，你是一个与人谈判的房地产开发商，比如大多数人绝不会认为自己有资格去谈判的承包商，这其实就是你谋生的手段。没错。而我却无法与这个系统谈判。所以如果你想完整地听到那个故事，你必须订阅《一条胳膊和一条腿》。
they were slick enough to do is what you actually do for a living. Right. And I can't negotiate this system. And so if you want to hear that story and it's entirety, you have to subscribe to an arm and a leg. Thank you Dan, I appreciate it. Oh Roman, thank you so much. 99% invisible with produces weak by Dan Weissman and edited by Avery Trollfoman.
谢谢你，丹，我很感激。哦，罗曼，非常感谢。由丹·韦斯曼制作、艾瑞莉·特罗尔福曼剪辑的《99%隐形》。
Mix and tech production by Shereef Yusuf, Music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, senior editor Delaney Hall, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find more at radiotopia.fm.
混音和技术制作由谢里夫·优素福完成，音乐由肖恩·里尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德、高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔、乔·罗森伯格、维维安·李、塔伦·马扎以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心无线电街。“99%隐形”是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客中所有最具创新性的节目组成的、极其独立的集体。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解更多信息。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Orc. Or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But this week, I think it's a good idea to check out Dan Weissman's other 99PI stories on our website. Just use the handy search function at 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上 @我（Roman Mars）以及节目（@99PI Org）。也可以在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上找到我们。但本周，我认为在我们的网站上查看丹·韦斯曼的其他 99PI 故事是个好主意。只需使用 99pi.org 上的便捷搜索功能即可。Radio Tapio。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。